GREAT JOB AS ALWAYS.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO IF YOU’RE A
GOVERNOR AND GET THE EDICT FROM
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, OPEN YOUR CHURCHES.
IF YOU’RE OHIO GOVERNOR, MIKE
DEWINE, YOU NEVER SHUT THEM DOWN
OR RESTRICTED THEIR USE.
HE JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
GOVERNOR, VERY GOOD TO HAVE YOU
AGAIN GO GOOD TO SEE YOU, NEIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> NEIL: COULD YOU EXPLAIN NOW
-- I BELIEVE -- I DON’T WANT TO
PUT -- CHARACTERIZE IT
INCORRECTLY.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS SEEN CHURCHES,
PLACES OF WORSHIP AS ESSENTIAL
BUSINESSES THAT CAN’T BE
SHUTTERED.
I’M SURE YOU HAVE RULES IN PLACE
BECAUSE THEY OBVIOUSLY ATTRACT
LARGE GATHERINGS.
WHAT ARE THEY IN OHIO?
WHAT WOULD CHANGE UNDER THE
EDICT, IF ANYTHING?
>> WE’VE ALWAYS EXEMPTED
CHURCHES, SYNAGOGUES, PLACES OF
WORSHIP FROM ANY OF OUR ORDERS.
WE’VE SAID VERY CLEARLY THAT OUR
SUGGESTION IS THAT PEOPLE BE
EXCEEDINGLY CAREFUL, NOT HAVE
BIG CONGREGATIONS GATHERING
TOGETHER CLOSELY.
AND MANY CHURCHES, THE CATHOLIC
CHURCHES, THE DIOCESE FOR
EXAMPLE IN OHIO, I THINK ALL THE
BISHOPS HAVE CANCELED SERVICES
FOR SOME TIME.
THEY’RE GOING TO BE OPENING UP
SHORTLY.
OTHER CHURCHES HAVE COME UP WITH
AMAZING WAYS TO DO IT.
THEY’VE EVEN USED DRIVE-IN MOVIE
THEATERS FOR PEOPLE TO GO, COME
INTO AND HAVE SERVICES.
THEY’VE DONE THEM VIRTUALLY.
SO THEY’VE DONE IT REALLY A
GREAT JOB.
A LOT OF THE CHURCHES I KNOW NOW
ARE PLANNING TO START OPENING
BACK UP AGAIN AND THEY’RE COMING
UP WITH GOOD WAYS OF DOING THAT.
WE JUST ENCOURAGE THE CHURCHES
TO BE JUST VERY, VERY CAREFUL.
LIKE ANY OTHER GATHERING
TOGETHER.
TRY TO KEEP THAT DISTANCE.
WE’VE ASKED -- SUGGESTED -- NOT
TOLD, BUT SUGGESTED THAT PEOPLE
WEAR MASKS AND THEY JUST TRY TO
GET THAT EXTRA LAYER OF
PROTECTION.
>> NEIL: IN THE MEANTIME, YOU’RE
CONTINUING EASING UP ON
RESTRICTIONS, THE LATEST IS FALL
SPORTS TRAINING CAN RESUME I
BELIEVE ON JUNE 1st.
YOU’RE ALSO LOOKING AT BANQUETS,
EVEN THOSE FOR WEDDINGS, IF THE
CROWDS DON’T EXCEED 300.
WHAT ELSE AM I MISSING OR WHAT
ELSE ARE YOU DOING?
>> WELL, YESTERDAY WAS THE FIRST
DAY THAT WE’VE HAD THIS LATTER
PART OF THIS WEEK, THE FIRST
COUPLE DAYS THAT WE’VE HAD THE
OPENING OF RESTAURANTS AND BARS
INSIDE AND I JUST LOOKED AT A
REPORT A MOMENT AGO IN REGARD TO
THE BARS AND MOST OF THEM ARE
DOING PRETTY WELL.
LAST NIGHT WE HAD TO REMIND A
FEW KIND OF WHAT THE ORDERS
WERE.
BUT THE REPORT WAS VERY GOOD.
I GOT A REPORT FROM A NUMBER OF
BARS AROUND THE STATE, THREE OR
FOUR HUNDRED, AND IT WAS A GOOD
REPORT.
WE JUST REMIND PEOPLE, BE
CAREFUL.
THE VIRUS IS STILL OUT THERE.
WE’VE GOT TO DO TWO THINGS AT
ONCE.
WE’VE GOT TO OPEN UP OUR
ECONOMY.
WE’RE DOING THAT.
BUT WE’VE GOT TO REMAIN SAFE.
>> NEIL: ALL RIGHT.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT OF THE 300
FIGURE, GOVERNOR AND I COME FROM
AN ITALIAN FAMILY.
300 IS JUST --
>> THAT’S SMALL, THAT’S SMALL.
NEIL:  YOU NIGHT HAVE ISSUES
WITH THAT.
LET ME SWITCH GEARS.
GO AHEAD.
>> WE’VE EXEMPTED WEDDINGS AND
FUNERALS.
THE REAL QUESTION THERE WAS THE
WEDDING RECEPTION AND CATERERS
CAME TO US AND SAID, LOOK, WE’VE
GOT A FACILITY.
WE CAN RUN THIS LIKE A
RESTAURANT AND WE CAN HAVE THE
SPACE.
SO WHAT WE’VE SAID IS UP TO 300,
YOU CAN DO.
BUT AGAIN, YOU’VE GOT TO FOLLOW
THE SPACING, YOU’VE GOT TO DO
THE SAME THINGS WE’RE REQUIRING
OF RESTAURANTS TO DO.
NEIL:  A LOT OF IT IS VERY
COMMON SENSE STUFF.
LET ME ASK YOU A LITTLE BIT
RIGHT NOW, THIS COMES AT A TIME
WHERE A LOT OF STATES ARE BEING
SCRUTINIZED, THE REOPENING, AND
WHETHER IT IS JIVING WITH
NUMBERS THAT SUPPORT THE
REOPENING, IN OTHER WORDS,
UNUSUAL SPIKE IN CASES OR THE
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE TESTING
POSITIVE FOR THE VIRUS REMAINS
LOW.
CDC RECOMMENDS THIS, NO HIGHER
THAN 3%.
I DON’T KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHAT
THEY ARE IN OHIO.
BUT WHAT WOULD MAKE YOU SLOW
THAT DOWN?
WHAT WOULD GIVE YOU PAUSE IN
THIS PROCESS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE’RE
WATCHING NUMBERS THAT ARE
PUBLISHED ALL THE TIME.
FOR EXAMPLE, TRAFFIC.
OUR TRAFFIC IN OHIO WAS DOWN 50%
AT ONE POINT.
WE’RE NOW DOWN ABOUT 10.
SO YOU’RE SEEING PEOPLE REALLY
STARTING TO MOVE AROUND A LOT.
AND SO THAT’S SOMETHING THAT
WE’VE GOT TO WATCH.
IF THEY DO IT CORRECTLY AND IF
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO DO THE
SPACING, THAT’S FINE.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE RISK
GOES UP.
AS FAR AS THE SPECIFIC NUMBERS,
ONE OF THE NUMBERS WE LOOKED AT
IS NUMBER OF HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS.
THAT HAS BEEN PRETTY FLAT.
WE’VE PLATEAUED THAT OUT.
IT’S NOT GOING DOWN BUT IT’S NOT
GOING UP.
THAT’S BEEN STEADY FOR ABOUT A
MONTH.
SO WE’LL KEEP AN EYE ON THAT.
WE’LL ALSO KEEP AN EYE ON WHAT I
REFER TO AS THE REPLICATION
RATE, BASICALLY IF I HAVE THE
COVID-19, HOW MANY PEOPLE ON
AVERAGE DOES THAT PERSON INFECT
AND AT ONE POINT IN OHIO WE WERE
ONE TO TWO AND SO THAT’S NOT
GOOD.
DRAMATIC SPREAD.
WE’RE NOW DOWN TO ONE TO ONE.
SO WE’RE GOING TO KEEP OUR EYE
ON THAT AS WE OPEN UP THE
SOCIETY AND WE DON’T WANT THAT
TO CREEP UP VERY, VERY HIGH
BECAUSE THAT WILL BE -- THAT
MEANS THAT WE’RE GOING OUT
FASTER THAN WE WERE AND THREE OR
FOUR WEEKS AFTER THAT WE’RE
GOING TO START TO SEE THESE
NUMBERS SPIKE UP.
SO WE’RE CAREFUL.
WE’VE DONE THIS WITH WHAT WE
CONSIDER TO BE THE BEST
PRACTICES.
RESTAURANT PEOPLE GOT TOGETHER,
WE PUT RESTAURANT PEOPLE WITH
HEALTH PEOPLE.
THEY CAME UP WITH BEST
PRACTICES.
DID THE SAME THING, PEOPLE WHO
RUN BARS, PEOPLE WHO CUT HAIR.
SO WE’VE COME UP WITH WHAT WE
THINK THE BEST PRACTICES BUT
OHIOANS, WE NEED TO STAY
FOCUSED.
WE CAN DO TWO THINGS AT ONCE BUT
WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL.
NEIL:  GOOD LUCK.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
OHIO GOVERNOR MIKE DEWINE, ONE
OF THE EARLIEST TO ACT ON
SHUTTING DOWN THE STATE,
SHUTTING DOWN WHAT HAD BEEN
GOING ON IN THE STATE, LONG